no more time left to discuss
you have been discussing the six package
of sanctions
for more than a month
a group of ukrainian protesters gathered
outside the building where the foreign
ministers were meeting to try to
finalize another package of sanctions
including a ban on imports of russian
oil
inside the meeting again deadlock 26
nations against one hungary even though
it's been given a carve out is the only
eu member opposing the new sanctions
that's causing some considerable anger
this is how we
will be remembered either the
union who managed to go forward and to
send a very clear message to russia or
who got stuck and now unfortunately we
are
the whole union is being held uh hostage
by uh one member state uh who cannot uh
find that could not help
help us find their consensus
the eu high representative for foreign
policy has been meeting canada's foreign
minister when i interviewed him last
week he was confident the new sanctions
could be agreed but he doesn't seem so
hopeful now we'll do our best in order
to de-block the situation
i cannot ensure that this is going to
happen because the positions are quite
strong
but i think that if we understand the
particular situation of some member
states
and all of us make an effort to do that
to present a united front against russia
and we'll succeed
the foreign ministers are being joined
by their ukrainian counterpart dimitro
caleb he's bound to put further pressure
on the hungarians to change their
position
james bays al jazeera brussels